welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is bonus day six
and we're going to learn from the second
richest person on the planet at the time
of this recording with a net worth of
195.1 billion dollars
mr jeff bezos
my job one of my jobs as the leader of
amazon
is to encourage people to be bold
and people love to focus on things that
aren't yet working
and that's good it's human nature that
kind of divine discontent can be very
helpful
but you really you know it's incredibly
hard to get people to take bold bets
and you need to encourage that and if
you're going to take bold bets
they're going to be experiments and if
they're experiments you don't know ahead
of time whether they're going to work
experiments are by their very nature
prone to failure but big successes a few
big successes
compensate for dozens and dozens of
things that didn't work
so you know bold bets aws kindle
amazon prime our third-party seller
business
all of those things are examples of bold
bets that
that did work and they pay for a lot of
experiments
i've made billions of dollars of
failures
at amazon.com literally billions of
dollars of failures
and you know you might remember
pets.com or cosmo or
you know you give myself a root canal
with no anesthesia very easily
none of those things are fun but but
they also
they don't matter what really matters is
companies that don't
continue to experiment companies that
don't embrace
failure they eventually get in a
desperate position
where they the only thing they can do is
make a kind of hail mary bet at the very
end of their corporate existence
whereas companies that are you know
making bets all along even you know big
bets but not bet the company bets
i don't i don't believe in bet the
company bets that's when you're
desperate
that's that's the last thing you can do
if you're giving great customer
experience
um there's the only way to do that
is with happy people you can't do it
with a set of miserable people
um you know watching the clock all day
so does that include work life balance
and all those things
yes but i would i use i teach um three
uh leadership classes a year at amazon
i'm a part of it
they're bigger classes but i come in and
teach a session and
i always talk about work-life balance
except i like to use the phrase
work-life harmony
rather than balance because to me
balance
implies a strict trade
whereas i find that when i am
happy at work i come home
more energized i'm a better husband a
better dad
and when i'm happy at home i come in and
better boss and better colleague
and so that that um
it's not you could be out of work and
be have terrible work life balance you
know even though you've got all the time
in the world
right you could just feel like oh my god
you know i'm miserable
and you would be draining energy and so
you have to find that
harmony it's a much better word and i
think for most
people it's about meaning people want to
know that they're doing something
interesting and useful and for us you
know
because of the challenges that we have
chosen for ourselves
we get to work in the future and it's
super fun to work in the future for the
right kind of person
invention is not disruptive only
customer
adoption is disruptive at amazon we've
invented a lot of things
that customers did not care about at all
and believe me they were not disruptive
to anyone so it's only when customers
like the new way
that anything becomes disruptive and so
really it's just
saying that you want to you know if
somebody comes to you with a business
plan that they claim is disruptive
you should ask them to explain it to you
in simpler language
and the simpler language is why are
customers going to adopt this
um why are they going to like it why is
it better
than the traditional way now that you
have about 600 000 employees i
calculated you're adding about 250
people a day
um you've mentioned that you're trying
to fend off day two yeah
and you've said that day two is stasis
followed by irrelevance
followed by excruciatingly painful
decline followed by death
that is why it is always day one yeah
yeah how does that work
well so day one and this is a phrase
that we use at amazon all the time i've
been using it's in my first
annual shareholder letter from 20 years
ago
um and we say it's always day one and it
needs to be day one for the reason that
you just
mentioned um and how do you so the real
question for me is how do you go about
maintaining a day one culture you know
it's great to have
the um the scale of amazon we have
financial resources we have lots of
brilliant people
we can accomplish great things we have
global scopes we have operations all
over the world
but the downside of that is that you can
lose your nimbleness
you can lose your entrepreneurial spirit
you can lose your
that kind of heart that the the that
that small companies often have
and so if you could have the best of
both worlds
if you can have that entrepreneurial
spirit and heart
while at the same time having all the
advantages that come with scale and
scope i think
think of the things that you could do
and and so how the question is how do
you achieve that
um the scale is good because it makes
you robust you know
a a big boxer can take a punch to the
head
the question is you also want to dodge
those punches you'd like to be nimble
you want to be big and nimble and i find
there are a lot of things that are
protective of the day one mentality i
already spent some time on one of them
which is
customer obsession i think that's the
most important thing if you can
and it gets harder as you get bigger
when you're a little tiny company so
you're a 10-person startup company
every single person in the company is
focused on the customer
when you get to be a bigger company
you've got all the mil you've got middle
managers and you've got all these layers
and the those people are on the front
lines they're not interacting with
customers every day
they're insulated from customers and
they start to manage not the customer
uh happiness directly but they start to
manage through proxies like
metrics and processes and some of those
things can become bureaucratic so
it's very challenging but one of the
things that happens
is the decision-making velocity slows
down
and i think the reason one of the
reasons that that happens
is that people all the junior executives
inside the big company
start to model all decisions
as if they are heavyweight irreversible
highly consequential decisions and so
even two-way doors you could make you
make a decision it's the wrong decision
you can just back up
back through the door and try again even
those reversible decisions start to be
made with heavyweight processes
and so you can teach people that
these pitfalls and and traps and then
teach them to avoid those traps and
that's what we're trying to do at amazon
so that we can maintain
our inventiveness and our heart and our
kind of small company's spirit even as
we have the scale and scope of a larger
company
i would definitely advise a small
stirrup company
to be as narrow and as focused as is
possible to be if you look at the
original amazon business plan
there was no hint of anything other than
books in it
and it was not on my radar i was
thinking i wanted to build
an online bookstore that was it and
um you know worked way better than i
thought it would and we launched music
and that worked better than i thought it
would and we launched
videos i think it's so long ago i can
really remember i think it was actually
vhs tapes is that possible
and um and that worked better than
we thought it would and then i sent
email to customers so i picked about a
thousand customers and i said
besides the things we sell today books
music and video what would you like to
see us sell
and the list came back incredibly long
tails almost like whatever was on their
mind at the moment it was like
i wish you sold windshield wipers for my
car and i was like
really windshield wipers that wasn't
done the business plan but
that's an interesting idea and so um
today we
basically if you're buying your
windshield wipers anywhere else you're
probably getting ripped off um
and so um so
it's been uh you know kind of one foot
in front of the other
we all have adversity in our lives i i
would i would i doubt if you really
you know if you know somebody any friend
or anybody that you talk to
um there's no lack of adversity and
the uh and by the way that's good
because it's what teaches us how to get
back up you fall down you get back up
it always happens and you know you get
certain gifts in life and you want to
take advantage of those
but you i guess my advice on adversity
and
success would be to
be proud not of your gifts but of
your hard work and your choices so you
know you may be
the kinds of gifts you get you know you
might be really good at math
it might be really easy for you that's a
kind of gift
but practicing that math and taking it
to the next step
that could be very challenging and hard
and take a lot of sweat that's a choice
you can't really be proud of your gifts
because they were given to you you can
be grateful for them
and thankful for them and but your
choices
you choose to work hard you choose to do
hard things
those are choices that you can be proud
of just find something that you're
passionate about i would definitely
on the career advice side the most
important thing
about your first job out of school is to
pick a place
where you think you're gonna you're
where you're learning per unit time is
going to be very high
you can optimize for a bunch of
variables and it can get very confusing
you know where is the location
you know what's the salary going to be
and all those things are worth
considering they're all important
but make sure you pull back after you've
done your analysis and say
am i also picking the place that i
believe my learning per unit time is
going to be the fastest
and you learn much more from a best
practices company than you do you learn
no matter where you go so if you go work
for somebody you're like god these
people are all crazy this is insane
you'll learn a lot
of negative lessons that you can use
later and you cannot do those things
but that process of elimination method
takes a long time
um so it's better to try and find a
place that has really high hiring
standards some of the basics especially
you know a place that's
trying to recruit only the you know the
you know
a's higher a's and b's higher c's and
c's higher ds
so you've got to hire only a's and you
need to pick a company that's doing
those kinds of fundamental practices
well because then you'll learn so much
it'll set you up to do other things so i
would say that's probably the best
career advice i can give there are a few
things i think
if you want to be an innovative company
that you you have to do
first of all i think innovation is a
point of view
you have to actually select people that
are part of the company who want to
innovate and explore
being a pioneering company
an explorer company isn't for everybody
some people wake up in the morning and
they get their
energy the thing they think about in the
shower is they start their annual
planning process or however you want to
think about it with
who are the three companies that we're
going to kill this year that's the
conqueror mentality
and it's a competitor-focused mentality
instead of a customer focused mentality
and there's nothing that that mentality
can succeed by the way
so i'm not claiming you know the
pioneering explorer
approach is the only effective one
but when you've when you attract people
who have the dna of pioneers and the dna
of explorers
you build a company of like-minded
people who want to invent
and that's what they think about when
they get up in the morning how are we
going to work backwards from customers
and build a great service or a great
product
you you you that's uh that's a key
element
in to invention okay and that part is
fun by the way
so if you're the right kind of person
and you like to invent you like
change uh and you everything you see as
you move about the world you think how
it could be improved
that's just fun and we at amazon we've
over the last
18 plus years attracted a bunch of
people like that
and we have a ton of fun doing it any
young person
even before they start their career is
to really think about their
choices because i find
young people and i i when i was young i
had i made this mistake too
you can get very fixed on your
gifts so everybody has gifts you know
you you have gifts and you have things
that you didn't get gifted maybe you're
extremely beautiful maybe you're
extremely good at mathematics maybe
you there are a lot of things that you
can be given
but those things can confuse you because
they're not the things that construct
your life
it's your choices that construct your
life
not your gifts you can celebrate your
gifts be proud of them be happy of them
actually don't be proud of them be
celebratory of them but you can't be
proud because they're gifts they were
given to you you didn't earn them
you can only be proud of the things you
earn and so
as i got older i started to realize i
wasn't proud of my
gifts i was always good at school school
was always easy for me
and i was always proud that i was a
great student i got a's in all my
classes
i was good at math all of that and i
thought
i thought that's who i was but it's not
true
those are the things that are gifts what
was hard for me is deciding to work hard
deciding to use my gifts in certain ways
to challenge myself to do things that i
didn't think i could do to put myself in
uncomfortable situations
we all get i would say to a young person
you can choose a life
of ease and comfort or you can choose a
life
of service and adventure which one of
those when you're 90 years old
are you going to be more proud of what
do you say to employees
when you have obviously have some
traders in the stock who are not happy
and suddenly the stock is down 25
after a quarter well i so
for well since 1997 at almost every all
hands meeting we have two all hands
meetings a year
at almost every all hands meeting i
remind
employees that you know if the stock is
up 10
this month don't feel 10 smarter because
when the stock is down 10
some month you're going to have to feel
10 dumber and it's not going to feel as
good
and so it's you know ownership is
uh we give most of our compensation uh
is is done in terms of uh stock
compensation
and uh and part and parcel with
ownership is a mentality of
of long-term thinking you know you
owners think longer term than renters do
so i have a friend who rented his house
to some tenants and
instead of getting a christmas tree
stand at christmas they just nailed the
christmas tree into the hardwood floors
of the house no owner would ever do that
and um but sometimes that's a bad tenant
you know they're good
good tenants but that's a bad tenant and
it's because you know this is the same
old
thing about you know nobody ever washed
a rental car
and um you you take better care of the
things that you own and
and uh but but one of the
responsibilities of ownership
and definitely deep inside the amazon
culture
is to think about the fundamentals of
the business and not the daily
fluctuations in the stock price
it's no there's no information in it do
you shop on amazon
yeah and uh if you have something the
service you don't like yeah
so do you just pick up the phone call
your team of 700 000 people
and tell them i don't like this change
this or you know what i do so
um i don't do this it doesn't happen
that often but if i get a
delivery that i don't like maybe like
it's packaged or something
we have regular meetings of the senior
executive team
and i bring the box to the meeting and
when i walk in i haven't done this in a
while it's been a while but when i
bring in a box everybody in the room is
like oh no he's bringing in a box
because it's always some problem but
really the way i get feedback
is to is primarily from my email address
is very well known and i keep it well
known and i get
hundreds and hundreds of emails every
day from customers
and they always have something
interesting to say when something goes
wrong
because we have hundreds of millions of
customers around the world and no matter
how good we are
we can still be better you can always be
better
customers have a divine discontent and
they teach you if you listen to
customers
so we watch for that and we see patterns
and we can find places where it's not
working
something's going wrong and that's
really how i get the feedback
is from customer input and often you
know
in all caps angry you ruined my child's
birthday because the gift didn't show up
on time
and we take that and what you really
want to do
is you take that it's an anecdote it's a
single example
but you need to find the root cause what
went wrong
deep inside the system how did this
happen because then you can fix it for
everyone
so that particular problem will never
happen again you don't just fix the
symptom you have to fix the root cause
and that's been the secret to our
operational success for 20 years
my opinion is that i can do some things
that amazon
that would be hard for other people to
do only because of
my history with the company and
my as the company has grown of course my
job has changed very much
and it has my main job today is i'm kind
of the
i i i work hard at helping to maintain
the culture
um you know a culture of high standards
of operational excellence of
uh you know of inventiveness of
willingness to fail
uh willingness to make bold experiments
i'm the i'm i'm
i'm you know i'm the guy i'm the
counterbalance to the institutional know
who can say yes
but i won't you know i'm not going to be
here forever amazon is a really
many of the traits that make amazon
unusual
are now deeply ingrained in the culture
in fact if i wanted to change them i
couldn't if i decided
tomorrow that i wish amazon did less
pioneering
and more close following i couldn't do
it
the culture is um is
you know cultures are self-reinforcing
and that's a good thing
um you know the the the people who come
to the company
we get sometimes people come to the
company and they can't they're
they find amazon very boring because we
don't have enough you know competitive
zeal
you know we don't wake up some annual
planning processes and
some companies literally start with who
are our three biggest enemies
and then you know here's how we're going
to hold them at bay or defeat them
and we don't have such a list at amazon
it's not how our annual planning process
works
and so but if you're on the other hand
if you're the kind of person who gets up
in the morning and says
in the shower time you know what can we
invent for customers and what can we do
differently and
how can we improve that experience and
so on and so on then you know then it's
going to be a playground
is there i still run into work by the
way i took my family on vacation
to france my wife's extended family
there about 20 of us
and we had an unbelievably good time
great food everything were there for a
week i got back to seattle and i ran
into the office i'm having so much fun
to be innovative you have to experiment
if you want to have more invention
you need to do more experiments per week
per month per year per decade it's that
simple
you cannot invent without experimenting
and here's the other thing about
experiments
lots of them fail if you know it's going
to work in advance
it is not an experiment
and what happens in big organizations
that amazon's a big organization now too
the air force is a big organization
is that we start to confuse
experimentation
with operational excellence so
we you know operational excellence is
one of our four key principles that
amazon
we're building a fulfillment center
we've built over 150 large fulfillment
centers around the world now
we know how to do that that is not an
experiment
if we build the 151st fulfillment center
and screw it up that's just
a failure that's not the kind of failure
we're seeking
we want failures where we're trying to
do something new untested never proven
that's a real experiment and they come
in all scale sizes
there's your completely massive and
globally dominant commerce business
first party and third party
there is aws amazon web services which
came out of nowhere and it's now massive
you're in the hardware business
including echo and kindle and and the
phone
grocery delivery payments tv
shows you're now making tv shows
advertising
jeff how can you possibly do all of that
exhausting me
how can you possibly do all of that and
do it okay
even okay let alone good so
i think one way to think about this is
what are you really focusing on
so um you know i'm focusing
on those things that i think make amazon
unusual
uh genuine customer obsession
so like every single thing you just
mentioned when
you know when our senior executives sit
down and review those
programs they're looking for customer
obsession
the question was why
why did we expand into things like
electronics tools and kitchen
since those businesses are not today
profitable
and the answer is that um
that it increases our addressable market
size so
we can ultimately build a much larger
company by entering into those new
product categories
and and second while it's true that
those
new categories which are only three
years old and by the way electronics
tools and kitchen is now
a 600 million dollar business at
amazon.com which makes it
one of the largest on and it's on a
standalone basis it's probably in the
top four
or five e-commerce companies anywhere in
the world
so that business is growing and growing
very rapidly and has it one of the big
advantages
has a huge audience of early adopters
which is why companies like segway
choose us as the exclusive launch
platform for products like that because
really early adopters are the kind of
people who buy stuff like this
so it's uh but that business
ultimately will be electronics in
particular in my opinion will be our
largest
most profitable business one day when
you start a new business
there are certain fixed costs that come
along with starting that business and
then the business has to reach enough
scale
so that the profit from the business the
variable profit
can cover those fixed costs there's no
side stepping that and it's just a
simple
investment issue my approach to
criticism and what i
teach and preach inside amazon is
when you're criticized first look in a
mirror
and decide are your critics right if
they're right
change there are two kinds of critics
there are well-meaning critics um who
uh you know they they're worried it's
not gonna work
but they do want it to work and so it
could be i can give you example customer
reviews would be one of those
um when we first did customer reviews 20
years ago
publishers or some book publishers were
not happy about it because some of them
were negative
and so it was very controversial
practice at that time but we thought it
was right and so we stuck to our guns
and
and and had a deep kill on that and
didn't didn't didn't change
um but uh there's a second kind
of critic which is the self-interested
critic and they come in all shapes and
sizes
you know they're um so they can be any
kind of institution
competitors um of course
and so when you are doing something a
new way
and if customers embrace the new way
what's going to happen is incumbents who
are practicing the older way
are not going to like you and they're
going to be self-interested critics and
so you do need as you're looking
yourself in the mirror to try and tease
those two things apart
one of the unusual things that we do in
the kindle device business is we sell
our
hardware near break even and so we
make money when people use the device
not when they buy the device and that is
very aligning
with customers um if i buy a device and
i
put in my desk drawer and never use it
then amazon doesn't deserve to make any
money
likewise it causes us to have the right
kinds of
behaviors so for example if we're not
making money when people buy the device
then we don't need people to be on the
upgrade treadmill
they can we have people who are still
using five-year-old kindle ones and
we're perfectly happy about that
aws is very similar because it's a
pay-as-you-go
service we are not incented to get
people to
overbuy hardware to operate at low
utilization rates
our point of view on this is if we can
arrange
things in such a way that our interests
are aligned with our customers
then in the long term that will work out
really well
for customers and it'll work out really
well for amazon
there are a couple of other things that
are essential for innovation
and invention that are not as fun
one of them is you have to have a
willingness to fail
you have to have a willingness to be
misunderstood for long periods of time
if you do something in a new way i don't
care
what it is people are initially
going to misunderstand it relative to
the traditional way
and they will they'll be well-meaning
critics
who you know genuinely want the best
outcome but they're worried about this
new way
and they'll also be of course
self-interested critics
who have a vested interest in the
traditional they have some profit stream
tied to the traditional way
um but but doing things and if you want
to if you never want to be criticized
for goodness sake don't do anything new
so
it's it's it's okay though if you have a
willingness to be misunderstood for long
periods of time
if you have a willingness to fail then
what you can do is you can ramp up your
rate of experimentation
so successful invention successful
invention is inventions that customers
care about
it's actually relatively easy to invent
new things that customers don't care
about
but successful invention
if you want to do a lot of that you
basically have to increase your rate of
experimentation
and that you can think of as a process
how do you go about
organizing your systems
your people
all of your assets your own daily
life and how you spend time how do you
organize those things to increase your
rate of experimentation
because not all of your experiments are
going to work you need
people who and this is very tricky
you need people who are experts
in a certain domain area because the
world is so complex today it's really
hard to invent something if you're
if you're not an expert if you don't
have the underlying
tools at your disposal and know what's
going on you can't
you know invent something in
neurosurgery without knowing something
about neurosurgery
it's just going to be very difficult
because we're very advanced and that's
true in every
every field of endeavor but to really be
an inventor
you have to combine that expertise with
the beginner's mind
you have to have a certain child-like
ability
to not be trapped by your expertise
and that fresh look that beginner's mind
once you're an expert
is unbelievably hard to maintain but
great inventors are
always looking they have a certain
divine discontent and they they may have
seen something a thousand times and
still
it occurs to them that that thing even
though they're accustomed to it
could be improved and that's you know
you have to look for people like that
and i also think cultures support that
you know you can't even if you're that
kind of person
if you're in a culture that doesn't
support failure
you know willingness to fail is critical
for invention willingness to be
misunderstood for long periods of time
you know most inventions don't really
work that well in the beginning
they're clumsy they're little toddlers
they're always falling and tripping
and so you have to have a a a culture in
your organization that supports this
kind of
stumbling and wandering uh you know you
want just because you're wandering
doesn't mean you're lost
and that's a really important thing to
keep in mind when you're
trying to invent i tell senior
you should have the least stress you
know there's this weird
i think false uh idea
that ceos i'm a ceo there's this false
idea that ceos are under the most stress
well i look at that i'm like why you're
in charge
why don't you delegate the stress it's
your choice
and so it's you have to figure out how
to
set up your life in such a way that you
can minimize the things
from the very beginning in 1994 when i
came across this fact that the web was
growing at 2 300
a year i was working on wall street very
specialized kind of investment bank
called a quantitative hedge fund a
company called de shaw
and i when i
decided i was going to do this crazy
thing i went and told my boss
and he said well let's go for a walk
so we went on a two-hour walk in central
park
and he actually thought it was a good
idea it's a very smart guy his name is
david shaw he's one of the few people i
know who has a fully developed left
brain affordable right brain just a
super smart guy
and he said this is a great idea but it
would be a better idea for somebody who
didn't already have a good job
and
and uh that was actually a compelling
argument to me
and so i went away he convinced me to
think about it for two more days
and it was very hard to make that
decision
and until i found the right framework in
which to make the decision
i think because i know there are a lot
of people who are interested in
entrepreneurial activities out there
i think this could be useful it's
it's that it's the right framework for
me anyway to make the kind of decision
was a regret minimization
framework so i projected myself into the
future and i'm 80 years old and i'm
looking back on my life
what do i want to have done at that
point i want to minimize all the regrets
that i have
and i knew that when i was 80 there was
no chance that i would
regret having walked away from my 1994
wall street bonus or any of that kind of
thing i wouldn't even remember that
but i did think there was a chance that
i might regret not having participated
somehow in this thing that i thought was
going to be very exciting called the
internet
and and i also knew that if i tried and
failed i wouldn't regret that so once i
thought about it that way
it become became incredibly easy to make
that decision
what i want to achieve with blue origin
is to build the heavy lifting
infrastructure that
allows for the kind of dynamic
entrepreneurial explosion of thousands
of companies in space
that i have witnessed over the last 21
years on the internet
so when i think about the founding of
amazon.com it it only could work
so it'll take you back to 1995
july 1995 we open our doors and
this is a 10 person company i'm driving
the packages to the post office myself
and we had we were sitting on a bunch of
heavy lifting infrastructure
otherwise a tiny company could never
have started amazon.com you couldn't do
it
for example there was already a gigantic
logistics network
called the us postal service and ups and
fedex
that would have been tens of billions
actually hundreds of billions of dollars
of capital that you would have had to
have laid out if you had to
build a logistics network we didn't have
to do that it existed that heavy lifting
was already done
um the the the internet itself
was sitting on top of at that time
the long distance phone network again
tens of billions
hundreds of billions of dollars of
capital put in place for long distance
phone calls
but repurposed for the internet um
payment system there was already a
payment system we didn't have to do that
it was called the credit card and it had
been initially put in place for
travelers
and so on and so on and you can go
through and what we were able to do
is take all of that heavy lifting
inference infrastructure
and kind of reassemble it in a new way
and do
something new and inventive with it and
that's
one lens through which you can view the
founding of amazon.com
in space today that is impossible on the
internet today
you know two kids in their dorm room can
reinvent an industry
that's how how uh because
you don't you the heavy lifting
infrastructure is in place
for that today two kids in their dorm
room can't do anything interesting in
space
you know you could build a cubesat
there's not that much interesting about
cubesats
and the uh it'll be that may change but
right now there's just
you need there are certain laws of
physics and certain things you need size
for
and things need to be big we need to be
able to put big things in space
at low cost and so if i'm 80 years old
and i can say to myself
that blue origin did the heavy lifting
you know i'm using my amazon winnings to
do a new piece of heavy lifting
infrastructure
which is low cost access to space
vehicles have to be reusable you can't
throw them away throw away space
vehicles every time you're never going
to lower the cost
so we're trying to lower the price of
admission into space
so that thousands of entrepreneurs can
then do amazing surprising things nobody
in nineteen years
that much nobody in 95 predicted
snapchat
you know it's like i can't predict for
you what amazing entrepreneurs brilliant
amazing entrepreneurs will do in space
but i know if i give them low cost
access to space some brilliant
you know 22 year old is going to figure
it out it's one of those things about
what companies get sustainable it's
those that provide
platforms upon which others can build if
you amazon just
empower others empower others to do
things
so aws is like that kindle direct
publishing is like that
are third-party selling businesses like
that fulfilled by amazon is like that
every time you figure out some way of
providing tools and services that
empower
other people to deploy their creativity
you're really onto something you cannot
invent and pioneer
if you cannot accept failure to
to invent you need to experiment and if
it's if you
know in advance that it's going to work
it is not an experiment and so that's a
very important thing you you know
it's they are inseparable twins failure
and invention and so
you have to be willing to do that and
it's embarrassing to fail
um you know it's always embarrassing to
fail but you have to say no
that's not how this works if i said to
you you have a 10
chance of a with a particular decision a
10
chance of a 100 x return you should take
that bet every time
but you're still going to be wrong 9 out
of 10 times and it's going to feel bad
910 times
and in in with technology the outcomes
the results can be very long tailed the
it's very the payoff is can be very
asymmetric which is why you should do so
much experimentation
you know everybody knows that if you
swing for the fences you hit more home
runs but you also strike out more
but with the baseball that analogy
doesn't go far enough because with
baseball
no matter how well you connect with the
ball you can only get four runs
the success is capped at four runs
but in business every once in a while
you step up to the plate
and you hit the ball so hard you get a
thousand runs
and so when that when you have that kind
of asymmetric payoff
and you know one up one at back can get
you a thousand runs
it encourages you to experiment more
it's the right business decision to
experiment more it's also better for
your customers customers like
the successful experiments one of the
key
things about lean you know
defect reduction being efficient not
letting defects
travel downstream in any process if
you're
going to eliminate waste or as the
japanese call it muda
you have to have information
and
the data center has historically been
an information free zone as far as
application developers are concerned
you would write code and you have no
idea
how it's consuming resources you're too
insulated
because you're in a pool of resources
and you can't meter it one of the
biggest
still unappreciated
benefits of aws is that
application developers get a real sense
of which inner loop is driving all the
cost
yeah and that's a big deal so that and
that's just starting to that's one of
the ways that
that this approach to uh infrastructure
dramatically reduces costs in our in our
data center i mean in our
fulfillment centers and in our customer
service centers
we have um we're always seeking
to keep defects from moving downstream
so this is a
you know a principle that was
probably best applied in the early or
best first best applied by toyota
and they had this idea of what they call
the andon cord
which basically any
a factory worker could pull the cord and
stop the whole
automobile manufacturing line
and for old school
auto manufacturing companies that was
considered
crazy absolutely insane in fact the
opposite
principle was typically at work which is
you did everything possible to keep that
line running
and here toyota flipped that on its head
and they said look
anytime there's a defect no matter how
small
they want you to pull the cord and stop
the whole line
and um stopping things
you know if you if you do that in a line
that has a lot of defects initially you
get a lot of end on cord pulls and it's
very expensive and
but over time if you use that approach
you eliminate the defects closer and
closer to the source
and and the people who are
fans of lean manufacturing and these
kinds of techniques
take almost as an article of faith
although there's a lot of evidence to
support this in
very diverse industries that the further
a defect travels downstream
the more expensive it becomes to fix
and so you want to you want to stop
those things
you don't want them to repeat and happen
over and over
i spent an unusual amount of time with
my
grandparents and especially with my
grandfather on the ranch so he had a
ranch in south texas
and i would spend my summers there from
age 4 to 16.
and they when i was four they were
taking me for the summer to kind of give
my parents a break
you know sort of because they were so
young um
and it was useful i was a handful i'm
sure
and uh and anyway he he
he he created the illusion for me when i
was four years old that i was helping
him on the ranch
which of course could not have been true
but i believed it
and um and then as by the time i was 16
of course i was
actually helping on the ranch i you know
i could i can fix prolapsed cattle i can
you know we did all of our own
veterinary work some of the cattle even
survived
um and we fixed windmills and
laid you know water pipelines and built
fences and barns and
fixed that fixed the bulldozer that you
guys talked about
and so one of the things that's so
interesting about that
lifestyle and about my grandfather is he
did everything
himself you know he didn't call a vet if
one of the animals was sick he figured
out
what to do himself and uh so what does
it mean no delegation being resourceful
i think is the you know that you can
always you can't if there's a problem
there's a solution and of course as you
as you
mature and and get into the business
world and anything you do on a team you
very quickly realize that
it's not about just your own
resourcefulness it's about
team resourcefulness and how does that
work and ever since i was five years old
that's when neil armstrong stepped onto
the surface of the moon i've been
kind of passionate about space rockets
rocket engines space
travel i became a science fiction
reader and i've always known that i
wanted to
you know do something having to do with
space and i've spent a lot of time
thinking about it
for really almost my whole life and
that's one of the things you guys will
find
that you have passions and having a
passion is a gift
i think we all have passions and you
don't get to
choose them they pick you but you have
to be alert to them you have to be
looking for them
and when you find your passion it's a
fantastic gift for you because
it gives you direction it gives you
purpose you can have a job or you can
have a career or you can have a calling
and the best thing is to have a calling
and if you find your passion you'll have
that and
all your work won't feel like work to
you it's easy to have
ideas it's very hard to turn an idea
into a successful product
there are a lot of steps in between it
takes persistence
relentlessness so i always tell people
who
are you know who think they want to be
entrepreneurs it's
you need a combination of
stubborn relentlessness and
flexibility and you have to know when to
be which
and basically you need to be stubborn on
your vision
because otherwise it'll be too easy to
give up but you need to be very flexible
on the details because as you go along
pursuing your vision you'll find that
some of your preconceptions were wrong
and you're going to need to be able to
change those things
so i think taking an idea successfully
all the way to the market and turning it
into a real product that people care
about and that really improves people's
lives
is a lot of hard work i think probably
our most important piece of intellectual
property
is our brand name and i think people and
and i think this is very important for
anybody who's going to start a company
or
or or market an invention to understand
is that brands for companies are like
reputations for people
and reputations are hard earned and
easily lost
so the most important intellectual
property that a company can have
is for us it's that it's it's it's
amazon it's
that name but what it stands for we've
worked very hard
to earn trust you can't ask for trust
you just have to do it the hard way one
step at a time
you make a promise and then fulfill the
promise you say we'll deliver this to
you
you know tomorrow and then you actually
deliver it tomorrow
and if you do that over and over again
then ultimately you can instill your
company's
name with a reputation and that's i
think
you know sometimes people talk about
brands in this very amorphous way but
for me
i like to think of it as a person and
what is the reputation that that person
has and how have they earned that
reputation
we all get um gifts uh
we get certain things in our life that
are um
that we're very lucky about and one of
the most powerful one is who your early
role models are
you know you could they could it was
your grandfather it was in a big sense
my mom and dad but my grandfather too
and you know i had my mom had me when
she was
uh 17 years old and she was still in
high school
in albuquerque new mexico and this is in
1964. i can assure you that
being a pregnant uh teenager in high
school was not cool
in albuquerque new mexico at that time
and
uh so it's in in
so it was a very it was difficult for
her my grandfather went to bat for her
when they tried to kick her out of
school and you know he they're
they're incredible i had so the gift i
had is i had this incredible family
i very frequently get the question
what's going to change in the next 10
years and
that is an interesting question it's a
very common one i almost
never get the question what's not going
to change
in the next 10 years and i submit to you
that that second question is actually
the more important of the two
because you can build a business
strategy
around the things that are stable in
time and so as you pointed out in our
retail business
we know that customers want low prices
and i know that's going to be true 10
years from now they want fast delivery
they want vast selection it's impossible
to imagine a future 10 years from now
where a customer comes up to me and says
jeff i love amazon i just wish the
prices were a little higher
you know how you i love amazon i just
wish you delivered a little more slowly
impossible and so the effort that we put
into those
things spinning those things up
we know the energy we put into it today
will still be paying dividends for our
customers 10 years from now
and so those when you have something
that you know is true
even over the long term you can afford
to put a lot of energy into
it on aws the big ideas
are also pretty straightforward it's
impossible for me to imagine
that 10 years from now somebody is going
to say i love aws
i just wish it were a little less
reliable
or i love aws i just wish you would
raise prices
it should be a little more expensive or
i love aws
and i wish you would innovate and
improve the apis at a slightly slower
rate
none of those things you can imagine and
so
the big ideas in business are often very
obvious but it's very hard to maintain a
firm
grasp of the obvious at all times but if
you can do that
and continue to spin up those flywheels
and put energy into those things as
we're doing with aws over time
you build a better and better service
for your customers on the things that
genuinely matter to them
i picked books because there were more
items in the book category than any
other category and so you could build
universal selection there were three
million in 1994 when i was
pulling this idea together the the
the three million different books active
and in print at any given time the
largest physical bookstores only had
about 150
000 different titles and so i could see
how you could make a bookstore
online with universal selection every
book ever printed even the out of print
ones was the original vision
for the company and so that's why books
and when did you know
that amazon is going to be going to be
something way bigger
than just a bookstore well i knew that
the books
strangely because i was very prepared
for this to take a really long time i
knew that the books
um business was going to be successful
in the first 30 days
i was shocked at how many books we sold
we were
ill prepared um you know i had
we had all the we had only 10 people in
the company at that time and most of
them were software engineers and so
everybody
including me and the softwares were all
like packing boxes
we didn't even have packing tables and
down we were on our hands and knees on a
concrete floor packing the boxes
and about you know one or two in the
morning i said to one of my
software engineering colleagues i said
you know paul um we uh this is killing
my knees
we need to get knee pads and paul looked
at me and he's like jeff
we need to get packing tables
and i i was like oh my god that is such
a good idea
the next day i bought packing tables and
it doubled our productivity
and probably saved our backs and our
knees too my
greatest uh uh i would have such a good
feeling if i could be an 80 year old guy
and laying there thinking about my life
if i could say look there is
now a bunch of entrepreneurs in space
because i took my amazon lottery
winnings
and built the heavy lifting
infrastructure that does take
billions of dollars in capex to lower
the cost
of access to space that's how you get
millions of people living in workers
and by the way we need that for those of
you who like to think about the future
at all you can do a simple calculation
you know
we can argue about um you know what
limited resources on earth and so on and
so on but here's the calculation that
you cannot argue with
which is you take current baseline
energy usage on earth
compound it at just a few percent a year
for just a few hundred years
and you have to cover the entire surface
of the earth in solar cells
so you have to
we're going to have to decide do we want
a society
of pioneering invention expansion
growth or do we want a society of stasis
and personally because the earth is
finite and if you want a society of
stasis
i think it's good first of all i don't
personally believe that stasis is even
compatible with freedom
so i think for me that's a big problem
second of all
it's going to be dull stasis is going to
be very dull you don't want to live in
the stasis world
and so of course we're going to continue
to get more efficient too we have been
for hundreds of years we've been getting
more productive more efficient
that's that trend is going to continue
but even so
we're going to want to use more energy
more energy per capita
and also i don't want to stabilize
population i would love for there to be
a trillion humans in the solar system
with a trillion humans we would have a
thousand einsteins and a thousand
mozart's
it'd be an incredible symbol don't you
want that dynamism
it'd be so much more interesting my this
is for your great great great
grandchildren but what kind of world do
you want them to live in
i want them to live in that expansive
world that is
you know learning more about the
universe and moving out throughout the
solar system
if you want to be an inventor of any
kind inventing a new
you know a new service offering for
customers or a new product or anything
the being an inventor requires because
the world is so complicated
you have to be a domain expert i mean in
a way even if even if you're not at the
beginning
you have to learn learn learn learn
learn enough so that you become a domain
expert
but the danger is once you become a
domain expert you can be trapped by that
knowledge
and so inventors have this paradoxical
ability
to have that you know 10 000 hours of
practice and be a real domain expert
and have that beginner's mind
have that that look at it freshly even
though they know
so much about the domain and that's the
key
um to inventing you have to have both
and i think that is intentional
i think all of us have that inside of us
and we can all do it but you have to be
intentional about it you have to
say yeah i am going to become an expert
and i'm going to keep my beginner's mind
so your question is you know did i kind
of anticipate what would happen over the
last 22 years
at amazon and the answer is god no so
you know amazon started as a very small
company
it was me and a few other people i was
driving
all the packages to the post office
myself in my 1987
chevy blazer and
uh when i raised money for amazon i had
to raise a million dollars
which i raised from 22 different
investors 50
000 each they got 20 of the company
for uh for the million dollars
and um it was
a 40 people told me no so i had to take
60 meetings
to get 20 yeses the first question was
always what's the internet
and i had to walk through that and this
was 1994
early 95. and so did i anticipate
you know fast forward to today and and
the current version of it
no it has been one foot in front of the
other
and i think that that is true for most
businesses
where you kind of proceed adaptively
it's step by step
you figure it out you have a success and
then you kind of double down on that
success and you figure out what
what else you can do what customers want
there are a lot of things that are a
waste of time you know when you think
about your life
i think i i often tell people um that i
work with
if you can get because people people
have very high standards
for how they want their work life to be
and and i said look
if you can get your work life to be
where you
enjoy half of it that is a home
that is amazing because very few people
ever achieve
that because the truth is everything
comes with
overhead that's reality everything comes
with pieces that you don't like
you could be a supreme court justice and
there's still going to be pieces of your
job you don't like
you can be a university professor and
it's still going to be
you have to go to committee meetings and
you have to do you know
there are every job comes with pieces
you don't like
and we need to say that's just how
that's part of it
and and not resent those pieces or try
not to
but also try to minimize them i tell
senior executives
you should have the least stress you
know there's this weird
i think false uh idea
that ceos i'm a ceo there's this false
idea
that ceos are under the most stress
well i look at that i'm like why you're
in charge
why don't you delegate the stress it's
your choice
and uh so it's you have to figure out
how to
set up your life in such a way that you
can minimize the things
and i find people don't dislike hard
work
what people dislike and what is being um
out of control like they can't control
their life they can't control
their environment this happens to me
when i get over
scheduled i hate being over scheduled
i want some time to be able to think and
free myself
we all have the same amount of time in
the world nobody has more time than
anybody else
and when you become a very successful
person
one of the things you start to get over
scheduled
you have this event you had to agree to
do this and maybe last night you were
like why did i agree to do this
i have to go on stage tomorrow i wish i
were really with my family
and you know or i hope maybe not this
case let's say that you like this one
but
in general that kind of thing happens
and so you have to guard your time and
and try to say a little bit flexible so
that's
for me it's not a waste of time but i
like
to have some freedom of movement
rather than having every minute of every
day
scheduled when you buy over the internet
amazon
do you ever get the wrong order is
anything ever wrong what do you do
do you call up and complain or you don't
have any problems no i i
i i'm a customer of amazon hopefully
like all of you in this is there one
person full time your service is your
account
in this room is not an amazon customer
see me right afterwards and i'll um i'll
walk you through it
it's um i i yeah i get i have problems
sometimes um and i
and i treat them like the same way i
treat a problem that i would get from
customer my email address is famous
and i keep it and i read it it's jeff at
amazon.com i don't see every email that
i get anymore because i get too many
but i see a lot of them and i use my
curiosity
to pick out certain emails i'll get one
from a customer and
there's a defect you know we've done
something wrong that's the usually
people are writing us
not always but usually the writing is
because we've screwed up their order
somehow
and i am uh so i look at this and for
some reason
something seems a little odd about that
one and so i'll ask the team to do a
case study
and and find real root cause or causes
it's usually causes
real root causes and then real root
fixes
so that when you fix it you're not
fixing it for that one customer you're
fixing it for every customer
and that process is a gigantic part of
what we do
so i would treat my if i have a failed
order or some bad customer experience i
would treat it just like that
when i started amazon it was 25 years
ago
i started amazon in 1994.
when i went to see investors the first
question i had to answer
is what is the internet none of my
investors had ever heard of the internet
and uh the
the the the idea that i had in mind
was to build a bookstore i realized that
we could build a store
which would have every book ever printed
in any language in print or out of print
and we could do that online it would be
impossible in a physical store that was
the founding idea of amazon
and but did i expect what would happen
today no you know we
started uh i've been at amazon when it
was one person
me when it was 10 people when it was a
hundred people when it was a thousand
people
and today when it's you know more than
700
000 people and approaching 70 000 people
just here in
india so no i did not predict that
and actually i think if anybody had
predicted that they would have needed to
be immediately institutionalized in a
mental facility
because it's not a normal thing to have
happen my dream when i started amazon
was that one day we might be able to
afford a forklift
so it's been a very uh fun journey for
me
and by the way i still tap dance into
work i'm having so much fun
i ask everybody to not think in
two to three year time frames but to
think in five to seven year time frames
to not think about when somebody says to
me congratulates amazon
on a good quarter which is a very common
thing to say you meet somebody they're
being nice
they looked at your financial results
for the quarter of a good quarter i say
thank you but what i'm thinking to
myself is
that quarter all that those quarterly
results were actually pretty much
fully baked about three years ago and so
like today
i'm working on you know a quarter that
is going to happen in 2020
not next quarter next quarter for all
practical purposes is done already and
it's probably been done for a couple of
years
and so if you start to think that way
it changes how you spend your time how
you plan
where you put your energy and and
your ability to look around corners gets
better so many things improve
if you can take a long term by the way
it's not natural for humans so it's a
it's a discipline that you have to build
the um the kind of you know get rich
slowly
schemes are not big sellers on uh
infomercials you know it's uh and so
that's something that you have to sort
of steal yourself for and discipline and
teach
over time you can choose we all get to
choose our life stories
and um it's the choices that define us
not our gifts
everybody in this room has many gifts i
have many gifts
you can never be proud of your gifts
because they're gifts they were given to
you you might be
you know tall or you might be really
good at math
or you might be extremely beautiful or
handsome or
you know there or they're many gifts and
you can only
be proud really of your choices because
those are the things that you
are that you're that you are acting on
and one of the most important choices
that each of us
has and you know this just as well as i
do
is you can choose a life
of ease and comfort or
you can choose a life of service and
adventure
and when you're 80 which one of those
things
you think you're going to be more proud
of you're going to be more proud of
having chosen a life of service and
adventure
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free in the first line
of the description below and if you're
enjoying this billionaire mindset series
give me a hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you
to be innovative you have to experiment
if you want to have more invention
you need to do more experiments per week
per month per year per decade it's that
simple
you cannot invent without experimenting
and here's the other thing about
experiments
lots of them fail if you know it's going
to work in advance
it is not an experiment
and what happens in big organizations
that amazon's a big organization now too
the air force is a big organization
is that we start to confuse
experimentation
with operational excellence so
we you know operational excellence is
one of our four key principles at amazon
we're building a fulfillment center
we've built over 150 large fulfillment
centers around the world now
we know how to do that that is not an
experiment
if we build the 151st fulfillment center
and screw it up that's just
a failure that's not the kind of failure
we're seeking
we want failures where we're trying to
do something new untested
never proven that's a real experiment
and they come in all scale
sizes if you want to sign up for the
entire billionaire mindset series for
free and get the companion bonus pdf
calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there